this video is made possible by audible
with an unmatched selection of
audiobooks original audio shows news
comedy and more get a free audiobook
with a 30-day trial at audible.com slash
second thought
if you've seen films like gravity or
2001 a Space Odyssey you're familiar
with possibly the most terrifying death
imaginable slowly drifting away from
your space vessel watching it recede
into the blackness of space and
understanding that you have no way to
save yourself would be an awful way to
go but what could cause such a tragic
mishap and how likely is it that you
could be rescued in time when astronauts
step out of the ISS they're protected by
several systems first and most
importantly their spacesuit which
protects the astronaut from the void of
space and can supply up to around eight
hours of oxygen and one liter of water
the suit can be anchored to the ISS with
a long braided steel tether with a
tensile strength of nearly 500 kilograms
which keeps the astronauts secure even
if he loses his grip
finally spacesuits are equipped with
what's aptly referred to as safer short
for simplified aid for extra vehicular
activity rescue safer is basically a
nitrogen propelled jetpack with a small
joystick that allows astronauts to
propel themselves back to safety in the
event of a tether failure or other
problem these safety measures have a
perfect track record thankfully no
astronaut has ever been lost in space
but it's definitely possible and the
consequences of becoming disconnected
from the ISS are terrifying let's take a
look at that scenario in the event of
your tether failing during a VA you
would begin to float off according to
whatever forces were acting on your body
when you broke loose so for example if
you had attempted to catch a tool
spinning off into space and became
unhooked in the process you would slowly
drift towards the tool away from the ISS
at this point with nothing to hold on to
in a weightless environment you'd be at
the mercy of gravity no amount of
struggling could alter your course
that's where safer comes in in an ideal
situation you'd simply power on the
jetpack with the joystick press a button
to automatically negate any tumbling you
might be experiencing orient yourself
using directional thrust from the
jetpack then begin the slow and
nerve-racking process of attempting to
fly back to the ISS but what happens if
safer fails in a situation where your
jetpack refuses to function depending on
your trajectory and velocity your odds
of making it back to safety may be
either very poor or basically zero
if you're lucky you'll be drifting very
slowly and not in a difficult direction
and you'll have another astronaut on a
VA with you who could come get you
provided you're within the 26 meter
range of his tether if not you're pretty
much out of luck the robotic arm on the
space station is far too slow to capture
a small moving target like a drifting
astronaut and there's not currently any
vessel capable of rescue the Soyuz
capsules require a full day to power up
and undock and the space shuttle the
only vessel with a rescue ready air
locked compartment is in retirement so
unless a fellow astronaut was willing
and able to attach multiple tethers
together into one long super tether and
attempt a jet pack out to you you are
simply out of options depending on your
trajectory you might begin to fall
towards the earth when this happens
you'll begin to accelerate faster and
faster until you experience the
unpleasant fate that is burning up on
re-entry if instead your trajectory was
away from the earth you'd simply be
captured in its orbit and have the
remainder of your few hours of oxygen to
contemplate your mistake depending on
your personality this could be the very
worst death imaginable or a fairly
peaceful way to go you'd have some water
available to you so you wouldn't die
thirsty you'd get to watch the Sun rise
and set about five times and see the
continents and lights of civilization
drift by far below you then when your
air runs out you'll lose consciousness
and fade away over the next 10 or 20
years your bodies orbit will slowly
decay and eventually you'll fall back
towards the earth and receive a free
cremation courtesy of gravity if you
want to vicariously experience that
visceral fear of drifting away into the
dark void of space
go watch gravity or this scene in 2001 a
Space Odyssey or if you're like me and
like to drive a lot or have a long
commute listen to the audio book of 2001
on audible for free it's one of my
favorite books and I seriously can't
recommend it highly enough audible is a
great way to learn more about
fascinating subjects or just listen to
your favorite books on the go
and unlike streaming or rental services
your books on audible are yours forever
audible content includes an unmatched
selection of audio books original audio
shows news comedy and more from leading
audio book publishers broadcasters
entertainers magazine and newspaper
publishers
and business information providers if
you enjoyed the topic of this video I
also highly recommend astronaut Chris
Hadfield biography and astronauts guide
to life on Earth with audible you can
download and listen to books like these
on just about any device and if it turns
out you don't like a book you chose just
swap it out with audibles great listen
guarantee sign up for your 30 day free
trial at audible.com slash second
thought and get a book of your choice
absolutely free if you're a fan of
science fiction give 2001 a try and tell
me what you think of it in the comments
below
visit audible.com slash second thought
to start your free trial today if you
enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe and click the little bell to
join the notification squad you can
watch my other space related videos by
clicking here or if you're in the mood
for something a little different come
watch me play games with a friend on my
new gaming channel thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next video